this new study expecting crimes to surge
this holiday season so hector mejia is
going to break down some reminders for
those of us maybe who haven't had this
problem yet it could happen so hector
what do we need to know
yeah i really could you know heather
i've had flowers and also deodorant
stolen right from my doorstep and we've
learned package thieves are added early
this year with a record number of early
online holiday sales these precious
packages are arriving at doorsteps a lot
sooner this year and there are some ways
to protect yourself so we've learned
about a study by cctv camera world
ranking nevada as number 22 where you're
least likely to have a package stolen
and they warned so everyone should stay
on alert every single day of the year so
the study points to a report revealing
that 43 percent of those surveyed all
across the country last year have had a
package stolen at least once and almost
two-thirds said they've been a victim
more than once so here are some ways to
prevent these thefts you can sign up for
tracking and text alerts this feature
will let you know as soon as an item
gets delivered you can invest in a porch
lock box those are designed with a code
that you give to the delivery service
and they lock up your item you can also
have your packages shipped to work or to
an amazon locker or even choose the
in-store pickup you can also ask for a
simple packaging that doesn't really
tell people what you're getting
delivered another thing to keep in mind
these uh package thefts happen all year
long not just during the holiday season
reporting live hector mejia live local
now some thief out there smelling like
hector i know yeah it's one thing to
have your flowers stolen that's horrible
but when your deodorant gets taken that
is excessive that is a felony that is
unacceptable offensive really hector
thank you very much